Investigators,
forensics experts,
true crime jocks...
nobody has seen
anything like this one.
Robert Wone decided
to spend the night
with three friends.
We have their story, that
an intruder broke in
and Robert was
stabbed three times.
One. Two. Three.
Bang!
The story just took
off from there.
The detectives walked
into a surreal scene.
The level of depravity
is stunning.
There were needle
marks on his neck.
Something was very off.
You don't take three to the
chest, lay there and die.
That's what makes this
story so maddening.
This case has
more questions
than it has answers.
There's no evidence
of struggle.
There was almost no
blood on the scene.
Where is the missing blood?
When I die, the first question
I'm gonna ask God–